Lisp is a language that was invented
back in the 1950s it is capable doing
functional programming but it's actually
often misattributed as being a
functional programming language in
general it's a so-called meta
programming language or a symbolic
programming language and it can be used
for any sort of tasks that you might
want to do it for it's a general-purpose
language Lisp it's been said that
learning Lisp just helps you be a better
programmer in general it opens up a lot
of different ways of thinking that are
sort of locked away in languages like
Java or C++ or or what have you it has a
few interesting ideas such as this idea
of Homo iconicity where the language
itself is written as a data structure
that you can represent in that language
this idea of meta programming where not
only are you programming in the language
to solve a problem but you can program
the language itself you can change the
structure of the language itself to make
it more suitable for a particular
application and even if it was just for
learning those concepts you become a
better programmer in other languages but
nonetheless it still remains a language
Common Lisp in particular remains a
language that's very very good at
solving modern sort of real world
problems I actually would sort of draw
analogy to physics a little bit like
good ideas ideas that are fundamentally
good are usually ones that stand the
test of time now computer science and
computer programming is not a very old
art so to speak it's you know less than
a century old however there are lots of
theories and physics for instance that
were sensible they allowed you to make
predictions for example the Sun going
around the earth seems reasonable you
see it but there was a kernel of an idea
later that the earth goes around the Sun
and that is a physical theory that one
turned out to be true but also stands
the test of time there are good ideas in
it that are fundamentally good and so I
think that just the fact that Lisp is
started in the 1950s and still has
something still has some kernel of an
idea that's good
I think makes it worth learning even if
it's not used
yes yes yeah so Lisp even still like
going back to this kernel of idea is
good at building a language that I want
so I can't think of anything that's
better than using a programming language
that allows me to build the language
that I need to express my problem the
stuff that I work on day to day is
quantum computing where there isn't a
lot of literature on how to wrangle the
problems that come up in quantum
computing quantum computing uses quantum
mechanics which is a very very different
mathematical language than just addition
of numbers for instance that it is a
very strange world where things have all
different types of rules so modern
programming languages don't support
expressing these constructs in a very
fluid way so often I need to build my
own sort of language in order to express
solutions to problems that I'm having
now you can do this in a language like
C++ or Java you can build your own
parser you can build your own compiler
you can build all of the things you need
to just be able to write solutions to
problems button lists it allows you to
grow the language ever so slightly in a
very easy way so that in Lisp directly I
can express these new constructs and
it's very helpful for these types of new
domains
we're actually extending the syntax of
the language so one example that I like
to bring up is read back in the days of
programming assembly if you wanted to do
something like a for loop you wrote down
this structure where you have like this
explicit jump statement you say and then
you have a separate counter somewhere
and it's all just a bunch of lines of
assembly nowhere in the assembly code
are you actually saying like for I from
1 to 10 or something like that but you
know the concept is there you know as
the programmer what you mean by these
instructions is a for loop what list
buzzes allow you to take that idea of a
for loop and actually syntactically be
able to write a for loop so it's not
just a library of functions it's
actually new syntax and new
functionality in the language but it all
does come down to assembly yes yes
absolutely yeah it all gets compiled to
assembly in the end yes yes that's I
think ultimately what
optimizing for is allowing you the
programmer to organize your thoughts and
most of the time in programming is spent
thinking and so that's the process that
I want to optimize in programming not
necessarily the efficiency of the
program although you can do that in
other things it's it's being able to
even get the solution to the problem out
on paper on the screen in the first
place yeah so instead of sort of taking
my word for it we did this little
program where I work where we had
college students interns come in and try
the language and try to use it for
solving some of these quantum problems
and the first reaction is like whoa
there are lots of parentheses if you
look at list code there are lots of
parentheses and then that's well the
documentation is sometimes a little bit
shaky in certain places but once they
kind of got through that that first bit
of the learning curve the feedback that
I got is that they could think about
their problems in a more in a more
fundamental or more structural fashion
that the language itself wasn't getting
in the way of solving their problems
it's that now they could express what
they think in a more direct fashion
without so much of an impedance mismatch
fortunately Lisp was originally defined
in like half a page of code like the
entire language and half a page of code
and in that page of code they had very
few concepts that that bring to light
all of these things that I'm discussing
namely the notion of s-expressions which
is how the Lisp language itself is built
how you write it
and following that this notion of macros
and meta programming how we can extend
the language and I think these two
things really bring to light how all
this stuff works
the special thing about this is that we
can interpret it in two ways it can be
looked at as code it looks like we're
doing one plus two times three but it
can also be looked at as data remember
that in Lisp we write out a list using
parentheses here we write out symbols
just as their names here so in Lisp
we actually have this explicit bridge